[Musique]
le voici le voilà le fameux village
d'édith butler paquet ville c'est cette
rue principale épicerie écoles dépanneur
clinique médicale
on y retrouve les services de base il y
à même ce bistrot d'inspiration
française
le nouveau chef vient de joliette
il s'est établi dans la péninsule
acadienne il ya presque un an
c'est un petit coin petite place betz
tranquille comme dit la chanson
mais là ce sont vraiment sa petite place
en effet à peine plus de 700 personnes
vivent ici dizaine d'années pas aussi
j'ai beaucoup de gens que je connais
avec son revenu finalement quand ils
travaillent à l'extérieur sont revenus
finalement s'établir à paquetville cette
raison le village est aujourd'hui bien
en vie contrairement à plusieurs
municipalités la population de paquets
de ville a augmenté ces dernières années
il ya beaucoup de régions rurales les
gros défi c'est de conserver les acquis
comme les écoles les services
nous on était capable de tout les
conserver même à l'école en une
augmentation des jeunes pour une petite
population de 720 manquera pas de 230
écoliers pour une petite municipalité
c'est excellent donc on conserve notre
population pour plusieurs régions
rurales du nouveau brunswick la
situation démographique et économique
n'est pas aussi rose des entreprises
ferment les jeunes partent à atholville
par exemple le conseil municipal a pris
les grands moyens
on a introduit ici des incitatifs
financiers notamment pour la
construction de maisons neuves pour
attirer de nouvelles familles richard
gall 1 est l'un de ceux qui profitent du
programme
ça va lui faire économiser en impôt
foncier sur sa nouvelle maison
je vais parce que c'est environ 3,5 à 4
milles de l'or pour trois ans de pas
noir pour autant l'heure
il aurait traité a vécu toute sa vie
atholville son fils par contre à fait
comme tant d'autres jeunes il a migré
vers le sud ce que je pense que le nom
d'un des prochaines années va continuer
leur des services puis la population va
continuer diminue puis on va demander ou
avoir besoin de plus et servais saint
louis c'est un jeu c'est un problème la
solution croit ce travailleur de
chantier c'est de miser sur le
développement économique régional
beaucoup de jeunes qui commencent à
revenir le job pour les autres pour
rester ceci c'est le document condamne
aux nouveaux résidents le maire souhaite
que le gouvernement s'attaque aux enjeux
de la ruralité
il fait une proposition aux partis
politiques on demande aux partis qui
sont dans place maintenant pour
l'élection du 14 septembre de mettre en
place un homme m mettre en place un
ministère de la table
malgré les défis des petits villages
l'optimisme et l'espoir sont au rendez
vous de l'avenir et en régions puis les
possibilités sont grandes en région
parce que tout est à développer juste
avant j'ai pas l'impression que ça va se
vider dans les prochaines années j'ai
l'impression que ça va on va attirer
plus de gens
des gens comme megan et maxime ce jeune
couple est venu s'établir dans le
restigouche
il y à bientôt deux ans ou à moriat cas
qu'on habite alors on n'a pas on
connaissait même pas le voisin porte à
porte
ici on peut promouvoir une business on
peut se faire des amis assez rapidement
les nouveaux parents ont trouvé à
atholville le style de vie familiale
qu'il recherchait même on habite en face
du maire actuellement puis la première
journée qui ont tari vigne quand il y en
a pas souhaité la bienvenue donc c'est
car maman on accueille chaleureusement
peu importe qui dirigera la province la
semaine prochaine la croissance
démographique surtout en régions rurales
sera un enjeu de taille pour le prochain
gouvernement
autant les libéraux que les
progressistes-conservateurs ont fait des
promesses en ce sens et pour cause le
nouveau brunswick pourrait devoir
combler plus de cent mille emplois d'ici
les dix prochaines années
[Musique]
non